foreign
looking around I feel guilty for how
good I've always had it I'm so high on
life every single person ever who's made
it they have had somebody or people in
their Corner your guilt
helps nothing
[Music]
what up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
greatest mental health and marriage
podcast that's ever been recorded I'm so
glad that you are with us and you've
joined us
man I have I'm a little bit over
caffeinated so I'm gonna try to tone it
down
when wild storms come through last night
and uh I didn't sleep much I don't think
any of us slept much but we're here and
we're ready to rock and roll if you want
to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-3291
and leave a message and we will holler
back girl at you even if we ain't no
hollaback girl and
don't forget to hit the Subscribe button
it makes such a huge difference and the
five star reviews make such a huge I had
no idea
no idea non-zero but here we are look at
me learning about how the internets work
in the worldwide hive mind thank you so
so much for being with us and for
hitting subscribe let's go to Tommy in
Pittsburgh PA what up Tommy
how's it going Dr John rocking on to the
break of dawn my man what are you doing
I am in the Florida Keys on vacation so
good times well thanks for kicking us
while we're down hope that was fun for
you I hope that was fun for you we're
all at work Tommy real cool man real
cool what's up
so uh I'll just get into my question
here uh a huge fan I've bought your book
um listen to all your stuff and it's
it's really helped me grow and and find
a lot of Peace but uh the question is um
the more your material and just
psychology material in general I read it
seems like everything of that makes up
who we are comes from our upbringing and
in our environment and experiences
nothing we do is really buy our hand
um and looking around I feel guilty for
how good I've always had it I'm so high
on life when it seems like so many
people are so low and uh this can also
manifest itself and feel like feeling
incredibly responsible for some of the
relationships in my life
um
man there's a lot here can I unpack
almost all of it is that cool
yeah
um
first thing is you're partially correct
and
so much of who we are comes from the
stories we were born into and the
stories we were told
and
um I always make a a a very intentional
point to point out that also who we are
is made up of the things we've done our
experiences the way we see the world the
people we've hurt the people we've taken
care of and so it's a mix of both okay
so just to free you from any
nonsensical guilt you may feel
every single person
ever
who's made it to whatever that means
that means they got their first job as a
plumber or that means they're a
multi-billionaire
they have had somebody or people in
their corner there is no such thing as a
self-made man or woman I reject that
notion it doesn't exist it's a myth okay
so
um everyone had a like a coach or a
business partner or a romantic partner
had some a grandparent teacher whoever
walking alongside him or a group of
people or someone who gave them their
first opportunity or somebody who said I
believe in you whatever that thing is
and even if you didn't have a
quote-unquote person you want to fight
me on that then I'll tell you that you
went to your first job on roads paved by
other people and use electricity on
lines pulled by other people and you
dial into your laptop on a computer made
by other people and we can just go down
the list here and so the idea that
you're sitting there Tommy and you're
like man
all these other people have just been
doing it on their own and grinding it
out and I've had this awesome life where
other people help me out that's not true
okay none of us got to where we are by
ourselves period
and
you've had more of a head start right
tell me how you've had a head start
uh I mean
uh parents that always took care of me
they never
got divorced or fought
um anytime I went through trials and
tribulations they supported me
financially emotionally they taught me
how to connect with people so I can have
friendships I've always been good at
sports and connecting with people can
kind of
pick up any talent that is thrown my way
and then I just feel like I've always
just been
able to like also just let things go and
enjoy the things that I'm into
um and uh like I said even I've
definitely faced tribulation just like
anybody else
um but
it's just kind of like how far do you go
back like even when I face difficulties
um I've had people that have shown me
how to overcome those kind of things how
to look at the good how to choose
gratitude and so it's kind of like
everything that's good in my life I feel
like
I owe to kind of how I was growing up
and
uh even the things that haven't been
good I learned from someone how to
overcome those and find relationships
and make them good so it's just kind of
like like I said feeling guilty of like
everything I owe to someone else
something I yeah all of us are in that
boat
and what I'll tell you is your parents
have given you the world
and one day you're gonna get hit in the
mouth in a profound way somebody you
love is gonna die 100 chance that
happens
um you're gonna get fired you're gonna
fail you're going to violate one of your
core moral values in a moment of
weakness
those things will happen because that's
the Ark of life
and so while they may have set you up
over here
they may have taken some of that burden
from you and it's going to hit you
harder because it's going to happen in
your 30s when you've got a mortgage and
two kids
and what I'm saying and the other side
of it is
my friends that I only had a single
parent
and they were working three jobs and
they were left alone and one of their
brothers is in jail and the other sister
they haven't really talked too much
anymore and they decided I'm going to
figure out a way to get through school
and I'm going to grind and I'm going to
do they've got that side they know how
to get hit in the head and they had to
get hit in the mouth what they don't
have is a path for how do I communicate
to this group of people and how do I so
everybody's got stuff to learn
what I'll tell you is your guilt
helps nothing
okay and so
you've got a couple of paths forward
here but I want you to start shifting
really hard man from guilt to gratitude
wake up every day and don't be like oh
man I don't have any Mike my parents
never fought thank God your parents
didn't do that be super grateful that
your parents are still married okay what
you're gonna have to do like so let me
give you an example for me
um
I was uh real real fast in high school
as a runner very very fast
and like full scholarship to college
fast and I was one of the weakest
members of my Texas high school football
team
and so I always have to put in the work
where I know I'm gonna have shortcomings
and so for you as you look around your
life and you say okay I got I got shot
out of the cannon ahead of
people in my class ahead of people that
aren't in the school that I'm at I got a
head start on this on this track great
what are you gonna do with that Head
Start you just deciding to walk helps
nobody
you deciding to help the people running
around you now you're talking about
changing your community changing your
life changing everybody's life and so
the question is not how can I tear up
this lottery ticket I got and throw in
the trash it's how can I use this for
maximum good for me my community my
neighborhood my country my family and
everybody in between does that make
sense
so
I want you to start choosing the hard
path what does that look like that may
mean your parents take care of all your
bills you don't have to work go get a
job
that may mean that your parents uh bail
you out every time you get in trouble
the next time say I'm not taking your
money this time I need to learn how to
deal with this thing
that may mean that you regularly
surround yourself with people who have
life harder than you
and practice Service practice empathy
practice listening
so that you get an understanding of not
just a conceptual understanding but a
real hard-nosed understanding that the
world is not
um for most people how you experience it
and then you become you you start
learning ways okay I can I can be of
support and service here you see what
I'm saying
yeah I'd say like the second part of
that is
I feel like the reason I've
like I I feel like part of the reason I
feel guilty is like I've had that life
punched in the mouth moment like uh you
know like suicide watch like life sucks
for like a month or you know a few
months and like
now it's like like I definitely like
live with Incredible empathy and
gratitude and so it's more so like
just not yeah bro but you're staring at
your belly button
yeah
you're great grateful and empathetic
towards yourself
and that just that just runs you around
in a circle man
you got to look up and see the world
around you and get involved in in other
people's lives
as they invite you don't come into some
sort of Savior as they invite you
okay so that's that's the second piece
is like
the incredible responsibility like I
have had friendships and relationships
where
I can see where someone's hurt comes
from or like what they're struggling
with and it's like I don't know
sometimes I'm like like
am I carrying too much of this and I
need to like
like I feel like I'm if I leave them
it's like just another person that
disappointed them like I can feel that
pain or like I put that on myself
yeah I mean you've you've got no
business in somebody else's pain unless
they invite you in
okay does that make sense like I do this
for a living and it's really hard for me
sometimes to be sitting next to someone
I love and or someone I care about or a
stranger that I just met and they're
telling me what's going on in their life
and they're not asking for my input or
my support or my help or anything
they're just they're just vomiting on me
and uh I have to make a choice to I want
to continue to get vomited on
or do I want to step back and say thank
you so much I appreciate your honesty
and you see what I'm saying like I can't
just jump in the middle of everybody's
issues because then I'm using them to
prop Me Up
and if you feel guilty about how the set
of cards you were dealt
and you're going around trying to solve
everyone's problems around you
as some sort of ways to make amends for
all this Good Fortune you've had
dude and then you're using people around
you very similar to someone who's
struggling with addiction who asks all
their friends for money all the time
you're trying to take something from
them to make you feel okay
and what that tells me at the core is
you don't feel okay with you and it
could be from guilt I'm actually not
buying the your full story if I'm just
being honest with you I think you're
super talented I think you've got great
family support and I think you probably
struggle mightily with depression it'd
be my guess am I right
I would say it's
like 95 percent of the time I'm really
high and then
the others would be the opposite okay
and then you feel guilty for feeling bad
don't you I feel guilty when I'm high
do you do you talk to somebody a
professional
I have
why'd you stop
uh
so I felt like so at that time I was
like really low didn't value myself
uh worked through a lot with like family
and friends and then went complete
opposite felt the best I've ever felt
and I feel like I've been there ever
since I've like feeling good about who I
am
okay I left all you're talking about is
feelings what are you doing
what do you mean exactly you are being
dragged around by a leash
and the the person on the other end of
the leash is your feelings
I felt really bad and then I felt really
good and now I feel great and now I feel
that what are you doing
are you in school
no I'm uh I just I finished my masters
like six months ago and I'm a Fisheries
biologist okay are you working
yeah full-time how's that going are you
contributing
yeah do you have good purpose I feel
like I feel like I create
uh like I'm basically I get to work with
improving Fisheries so that people get
to enjoy them with their friends and
family okay
um
here's what I want you to do I want you
to step back and begin to look at what
does purpose look like for you man
because it sounds a lot
I don't know man quite honestly I think
you and I need to spend some more time
together
um which means I think you should sit
down with a counselor and say okay I've
had these moments where it was really
low I had these moments where I was
super high now I'm kind of leveling out
into this is the rest of my life I got
my graduate degree I got my job
um and I've got a lot of good fortune
that I'm resting upon
what am I going to do in the next stage
of my life to be a contributor and not a
taker
what am I how am I going to be a maker
how am I going to be a like someone who
encourages others helps others supports
others and at the same time doesn't use
others for my savior complex what am I
going to do there
and begin a relationship with a
counselor not because you're in crisis
anymore but because you are looking at
head heading off into what comes next
for you in the world you want to build
for yourself you can't keep riding on
Mom and Dad anymore and they shot you
out of the cannon in in a profound way
awesome
and hear me say this again walking
around feeling guilty for your good
fortune does not help anybody
at all
looking around taking your eyes out of
your own belly button and looking around
at the world around you and saying how
can I be of service and care for these
folks how do I use this ticket for good
that's that's that's the greatest gift
you can give humanity and yourself by
the way
and maybe therapy is not for you great
get a group of guys and you all meet
every Monday night every Wednesday night
every Thursday whatever pick one night a
week you'll always get together you'll
always hang out and you be honest with
them you tell them the truth you invite
them into your life and maybe if you're
lucky two or three of them or one or two
of them will invite you into their life
and now you've got the making of a
long-term friendship long-term
relationships we can go from there
but I want you to pick your head up and
not just figure out think about your
academics and your life and yours
start looking around
you got a gift man you got a gift
tearing up that gift and throw it in the
trash doesn't help nobody feeling guilty
about that gift doesn't help anybody
looking for work and I use this gift to
be of the most value to the most people
around me now we're talking we'll be
right back
Delona here hey you know a while back
Society went off to rails and people
started to see sleep as like an
annoyance it's something in the way
right just chug another energy drink and
keep hustling and grinding my friends
sleep is not the enemy it's essential to
the way our minds and bodies function
and there are several things you can do
right away to start getting better sleep
first lay off the caffeine especially
after like 10 or 11 A.M and ditch the
screens at least an hour before bed and
I recommend getting a great mattress and
you can get a great mattress from my
friends at dreamcloud I speak from
experience here the right mattress can
make a huge difference in your sleep
quality it's why my family sleeps on
dream Cloud their mattresses are
designed to be soft and cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night and right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and 590 99
bucks and accessories when you use promo
code John deloney that's cooling pillows
luxury sheets and a mattress protector
so go to dreamcloudsleep.com and use
code John deloney today
all right let's go to Ashley in Columbia
Missouri what's up Ashley
hey John how's it going what's happening
I'm doing great how about you
doing okay doing okay awesome oh good
grief have you heard the show before oh
yeah lots of time Ashley
I'm not good at this I know you have
nothing to be nervous about you're good
what's up
so
um I had a baby back in October all
right it's congratulations in order
yes yes awesome congratulations very
cool thank you thank you
um but and so it's my second one
um it was my first one I experienced
like postpartum anxiety but with this
one I'm experiencing like the depression
and
maybe the anxiety with it
um I just I don't know how to navigate
that like through my marriage through
any of it like it's kind of new to us
and so
um I made a doctor's appointment to try
and get on some medication
um so we just got that taken care of
um but I just don't know like see you
you've already have you been put on
something
yes like I haven't been able to start it
has been finding a little bit of a tummy
bug but what would they give you
oh gosh
um that's all right that's all right
that's all right
um so I'm not sure
if nobody's told you this I'm sorry that
I'm the first guy to tell you this
anxiety and depression are on the same
trend line
okay they're just different ways your
body's trying to take care of you
and um this is a crass way to say this
but like having a baby is a human
explosion okay your hormones are all
over everywhere
and one of the worst demons about PPD
postpartum depression is or postpartum
anxiety whatever however your body is
trying to take care of you all the
switches and levers are all goofed up
all over the place
and everybody has a different
um
a different path back to homeostasis or
some people are forever different and
that's that's the beauty of it all and
it's disorienting right it feels like
you are lost at sea
exactly right and so
I want to First applaud you
because tell me if I'm off here
there is something completely unnerving
when your body is saying I need these
like I I should be enjoying these kids
these are my babies they're healthy
they're this my husband's great all
those stories
and then you go to war with your body
you get really frustrated then you get
down on it or you get spun up on it and
then you start to feel crazy and then
people around you start saying why don't
you just cheer up or why don't you just
slow down or won't you just rest and
it's like oh I hadn't thought of that
genius right and now it sort of feels
like you're against everybody
is that fair
okay absolutely okay
what in your current life oh so before I
get there
I want to applaud you for having the
courage to go talk to a doctor
my first note when you start talking was
call your OB GYN and go be honest with
how you're feeling okay what are some of
your
um as comfortable as you are saying
about loud what are some of your
low thoughts
um they'd be better off without me they
get the life insurance money
um they
do they really need me you know like um
gosh
um
I'm a horrible mother because I should
be enjoying every moment with them but
yet for some reason I can't
get past things I can't let things go I
can't stop worrying about the smallest
of things
um
it's like the worry and things like that
just steal the Joy from the day I can
get caught up on something so small and
insignificant that it just tears my
whole day apart my whole week apart
um what have you tried
well when you say tried what do you mean
what have I tried like between your
first baby and your second baby what
have you what are some things you've
tried to do
um
getting on a good multivitamin
just pretty much everything but
medication okay all right um I'm gonna
give you a couple other
um
things I want you to try is that cool
first thing I want you to do is to just
carry a note card in your pocket
and you're how old is how old's your new
baby
he's four months old yeah you can like
when you're like babies under like a
year you can wear any kind of awesome
zipper Class B things no matter what
nobody's gonna judge you right so I want
you in one of your zipper Class B bag
things I want you to have a note card
okay
and I want you to have a pen
and anytime you think the words I can't
or I should
I want you to write those down
and my guess is very quickly you're
going to realize there's those the cants
and the shoulds are going to circle
around each other
in one or two or maybe three very
specific things okay
these thoughts feel like they're coming
at you at a million miles an hour and
they're all around you like a video game
right and you're trying to shoot them
all down they're just coming and coming
and coming and it starts to overwhelm
you and then your body just says I'm out
yeah right what I want you to do is
begin to take caption to capture them to
take ownership of them okay I'm gonna
write them down I can't even enjoy my
babies today
is your body's way of saying hey we need
some rest
I should be able to fill in the blank is
your body telling you
hey let's ask for help today
and I know Instagram says mom should be
doing all these things
great my body's not there today
thank God I've got a husband who's gonna
show up
you see what I'm saying I want to begin
to take cat to every time you say the
words I can't every time you you think
the words I should I want you to write
them down and begin to look at those
okay
and ask yourself what is my body trying
to tell me
the second thing is
where in your life
do you feel unsafe
alone in my thoughts I would say
um
I don't physically feel unsafe or
anything like that here's another way of
asking where in your life do you feel
not listened to or unheard
oh man
I think maybe
I fear
talking to people because I don't want
to be a burden on them there you go
that's the magic word I I don't talk
okay
and so maybe your body is finding fear
in those who love you most
because somewhere along the way
you thought reaching out and telling
your husband hey I need this today and
it's different than what I needed
yesterday
that you're gonna burden him because he
works hard and he's probably tired too
oh yeah for sure and I'm just gonna
Circle this up I'm not gonna call my
mother-in-law who's offered to come stay
I'm not going to call my mom because I
don't want to bother them they got their
own lives
and you said it best
at the core that story is I'm a burden
my kids will be better off without me my
husband would be better off without me
I'm just dragging the boat down
Fair yeah
now on Allen head yeah
I need you to hear me so clearly
that's not true
feelings are incredible traffic signals
they are terrible uh destinations
and so I want you to rest and anytime
you feel like a burden
remember my voice saying you're not
and so then
the next question you have to ask
yourself is what are you going to do not
what are you gonna think you think
enough for about 15 people don't you
next question is what are you gonna do
okay
I would really really love to see you
get a group of grown-up friends away
from both babies at least once a week
that you can go be a grown-up with
the place for you cool
sometimes Bible studies and sometimes
co-workers
that's a dangerous combination but if it
worked for you incredible that's awesome
okay
will you go will you commit to going for
the next I don't know six weeks seven
weeks eight weeks
okay
the greatest gift you could give your
kids
is for you to go be with other adults
for a while
and to come back a little more at peace
and a little more whole than having a
two human beings treat your body like a
jungle gym and a filling station
the fair yeah
I also it's going to be hard to say
these things out loud
I want you to sit down with your husband
and start these with these words
the story I'm telling myself is
that if I ask you for some more help
you're gonna leave
the story I'm telling myself is if I
tell you what I need you're going to do
it anyway at the expense of your own
health and I'm scared to tell you what I
actually need because I don't want to be
a burden
now you know your husband better than I
do if you sat down and told them that
what would his response be
from a a dad of two young kids myself
will you give him the greatest honor and
gift and letting him love his wife
during this time
instead of considering yourself a burden
consider yourself giving him the
greatest gift you can give any modern
male which is the illusion he's taking
care of his wife
how's it sound
yeah
sounds good
if you can't do it for yourself
hopefully you can get there soon
but do it for him allow him to
participate
okay
all of this circles back to this one
important thing you are not a burden
you're a gift
always know that the end of that
sentence I'm a burden my kids will be
better off without me the ending of that
sentence is always that's not true
okay and I don't know if you are I want
to take this from you the first time I
the only time I but I did it for a while
when I sat down took medication my but
my buddy was at my doctor he was a close
friend of mine and so he could speak
some truth directly to me probably a
little more direct than he would to just
a normal patient and I'm probably more
stubborn than the normal patient
um I sat at my kitchen table with the
open package and I wept I just cried I
thought it was such a failure such a
loser
it's kind of how I feel yeah all right
like my last resort you know yeah and
hey here's the deal good for you it was
my last resort too
and you didn't have too much pride and
you didn't have too much
um
ego
to not go tell your doctor the truth
okay
so know this is not forever
and
sometimes we just need some help turning
the lights on or sometimes we need some
help turning the Alarm Systems down so
that we can sit in front of those we
love and say I need some help so that
I can have the energy to get up and go
take a walk outside so that I can have
the courage to go hang out with some
friends even though I feel like I'm
feeling my kids if I leave them for two
hours which you're not
okay the greatest gift I gave my wife
and my little young son at the time and
then my daughter down the road was I
went and got myself the care that I
needed
and then I didn't stop there because
medication is not going to quote unquote
fix it it's going to provide you a path
so that you can go do the things that
are going to make you well
that makes sense
yeah I'm really really proud of you
thank you
so what's your next step
get with his girls yes on Monday nights
and
sit down with my husband and
talk to him
dude you're awesome
and the third thing I'm going to put out
there is promise me you'll always tell
your doctor the truth and be in close
contact if you ever ever ever
start crossing over in some really
darker thoughts okay
promise thank you promise I promise
awesome hey you're one of the braver
ones I will talk to this week you
probably want to bring everyone someone
talk to this month
um
[Music]
proud of you proud of you
by the way one quick last thing sorry I
know everybody's fading it out
um you may want to check in with your
doctor and ask for some hormone panels
and some hormone testing I just thought
of that as I'm letting you go here
um that may be worth your time just even
if you're just getting a baseline to see
what things are going to look like in
two months and three months and five
months uh ask your doctor if there's any
sort of blood work or any sort of
hormone testing that would help too to
identify some of the chaotic the chaos
okay
um all right that's it I'll let you roll
we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
feel like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramsesolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right we're back here we go again
it's time for facts to your friends
[Music]
we've got to change this music
I mean from the bottom of my heart
all right you know what we're at
Smashing Pumpkins time now I'll take
Smashing Pumpkins over that
and I think truly hit a low point it's
it's lower than low
as the producer of the show that's a no
[Laughter]
Okay so
so I made the internets really
uncomfortable the other day and so
here's here's what I wrote
on the Instagrams
this morning I plan to take my
seven-year-old daughter on a Valentine's
breakfast date I got up early and got my
workout done
I told my daughter we were going on a
date and she said no
she wouldn't go
I was crushed and it really made me sad
but my sadness is not hers to carry so I
told her I loved her to the moon and
back and I would love to take her on a
date anytime she would have me
I then wrote parents manage managing our
emotions is our job not our kids even
when it hurts
damn people got opinions on that people
got opinions on that so I'm gonna
clarify
dig in a little bit and I am right and
you are not okay so here we go
here's some here's some clarity to that
Instagram post
the night before Valentine's Day I asked
my daughter hey I would like to take you
on a date tomorrow to get waffles or
pancakes just a special time with Dad
and and daughter she said no I don't
want to go I want to have my regular
morning
uh and then go to school and Mommy
drives me to school
I disregarded her feelings
I I asked her and she said no and I just
blew right past it and I moved into my
little fantasy land that she wanted this
date as much as me and I was telling
myself the story it's going to be great
for both of us and then 25 years from
now she's gonna remember how how dad
always showed up on Valentine's Day I I
create all these stories
now here's some backstory here
I've been a ball of tension and
frustration and exhaustion uh writing a
book the process for me it takes
something from me I leave something on
the field
um particularly this last book because I
had to dig into some stories I haven't
wanted to dig into in a long time and
had to be really honest with myself I
ended up calling a counselor after
writing it not because it's so dark and
but I realized I'm not doing some of the
things that I'm recommending other
people do to make their lives more whole
and less anxious and helping them be
more well
I need to go take care of so it was hard
it was a hard process and this sounds
cheesy and woo-woo but writing drains
the bloody hell out of me it literally
takes something from me I got deadlines
and editor friends coming to town kids
trying to be a good husband being on the
road got a show that we're doing every
day
and over the years I've become pretty
good at stuffing it down
um one thing that I feel really
confident about is if I say I'm gonna
get it done I'll get it done and I'll
get it done to the expense of everything
around me including my own health but
I'll get it done I believe strongly in
that
and
kids absorb tension
also for self-preservation they have a
highly attuned neuroception so word
coined by Dr Stephen poor just the
polyvagal theory guy and I'm Not Hook
Line and Sinker on polyvigal Theory but
one thousand percent I believe the
science is super clear
our bodies are always searching the
environment for threats
kids especially
if you think of it in evolutionary terms
they had to because they're tiny little
creatures
that always are scanning to say is that
guy safe is she safe is this situation
safe is that guy safe you ever
introduce your your kid to one of your
friends it's kind of sketchy
and they just hide behind your leg they
feel it they know
and I'm a thousand percent convinced
that my daughter feels the underlying
tension in my body
her little body's always scanned in the
world it senses my it sees my tense
shoulders and it hears the sharpness in
my voice it feels the tension in my
muscles when I hold her and so when she
says no this isn't her being a brat a
whiny little baby and I joke about it
all the time but that's not bad at all
it's her trying to preserve herself
and I gotta live with that
I've created a world where my daughter
doesn't feel safe and I'm not abusive I
don't yell I don't hit
I don't swear
but I'm a nuclear reactor sometimes
especially when I don't take care of
myself especially when I'm lonely
especially when I'm not honest about how
I'm feeling
and so if you've ever listened to
anything I've said
three critical important things are
happening so listen to me super super
carefully I can't think of anything I've
got more important to share than this
right here
number one
I'm gonna honor my daughter's request
for bodily autonomy
she feels unsafe around a nuclear
reactor which is what I've been lately
I'm going to teach her through my
actions that she should learn to trust
her body
and this also comes with consequences I
took her brother out
we go to breakfast every Tuesday I went
ahead and took him because that was our
normal routine and she missed a great
time and we hung out with the wait staff
and we made jokes now we've become
friends with the people at Waffle House
I love those guys and we ate too much we
had a blast she missed it so there was
some consequence there
number two
if I force her to go or I force her to
kiss me good night or I force her to
give me a hug when I get home from work
I'm teaching her that when some man
comes along
who is bigger than her or stronger or
has more power than her she should bow
before him and let him use her body as a
way to make himself feel better
and I refuse
to let my daughter go through the world
thinking it's her job to make sure the
men in her life are all happy and fine
especially at the expense of her body I
won't do it and I'm going to teach her
at a young age that she has autonomy and
she gets to say no
period
and if her saying no makes me sad or
hurts my feelings that's for me to deal
with because she does not have the power
to change my feelings because she's
seven she weighs about 14 pounds she
doesn't have that power I'm not gonna
give it to her
that brings me number three my
daughter's seven your kids 14 17 11 3
however old they are they don't have the
power to hurt your feelings or to make
you sad or to make you angry you are in
control of that and if you Outsource it
to your kids they will try to carry that
burden as long as they can until it
finally crushes them
when I took a step back I realized I
wanted to build some relational Equity
with my daughter on Valentine's morning
because it would be a gift for me
for me had very little to do with her I
wanted to take her out on a date that I
designed against her wishes because I
thought it'd be great for her
it's not my daughter's job to make me
feel okay
she can't carry that burden
and when I look around the landscape
I've worked with young people for two
decades
moms and dads our kids are being buried
under our expectations that they make
sure that we're all okay
that they get the jobs we want them to
have they drive the cars we think they
should drive they marry who we think
they should marry that they work they
get made and they major in the thing we
think they should major in
that we show up to the holidays that we
describe we prescribe for them even
though they can't afford it or they're
exhausted or they're working like crazy
they got two little ones
it's their job to make sure those little
ones are in our house so that we can
have our they're dying under our
expectations that they prop us up
and as the world has gotten increasingly
more and more lonely parents we have
transferred our need for connection onto
our kids
and now I've got
countless the number of moms and dads
I've met with who are like no my 14 year
old daughter's my best friend God help
that 14 year old
me and my 16 year old are best friends
foreign
like my heart breaks for that 16 year
old
because she can't carry your adult
friendship he can't carry your
friendship you gotta have grown-up
friends
and let your kids have their own friends
and here's one more note
a mother wrote me and asked about
spilling her guts after her husband died
she wrote she read this post
um and she wrote me and said hey my
husband died of cancer and now I'm
feeling guilty because I dumped all this
out and my kids saw it all
letting your kids see you grieving and
letting your kids see you devastated is
an Incredible Gift such a gift
because your kids if if they lose their
dad
or dad loses his job
or Mom is sick or whatever is going on
in your life
they're going to be sad and devastated
and frustrated too
and if Mom and Dad turn into concrete
statues and these stoic robots who just
go through life like nothing's affecting
them I don't want to show the kids I
don't want to scare the kids then what
happens is you don't scare the kids but
the kids go crazy because they feel it
and they look at Mom and Dad to see how
they're supposed to be responding and
Mom and Dad are just walking around like
automatrons
so the greatest gift you can give your
kids is to let them know that you're sad
let them know that you are devastated by
grief
just don't force your kids to make you
to be responsible for making you feel
less sad and less heartbroken that's not
their job here's how this looks in the
real world okay I wrote this one I wrote
this down mom is feeling so so sad this
is this is you this is a mom talking to
their kids
mom is feeling so so sad I lost my
friend my friend died and I'm hurting so
much inside
and I'm gonna go see a counselor visit
with my friends because I'm in so much
pain and if you're ever hurting I want
you to know you're not alone and I'm
always here for you for a hug a good cry
or to go for a long walk or maybe even
sneak some Girl Scout cookies
whatever you need I want you to know
that I love you and if you ever heard
anything like this
um
I'll be here for you
that's different then
mommy's feeling so sad I lost my friend
my friend died and I'm hurting so much
inside come give me a hug so I can feel
better your hugs make me feel so much
better
I need my hug so I'm not so sad and
lonely
now Mom has shifted her the burden of
her pain onto her kid and that kid's
gonna begin looking for ways to make mom
less sad less painful less angry to make
Dad less reactive
it's not their job
so back to my daughter I hugged my
daughter and said I love you and I can't
wait to go on a date with you when
you'll have me
and to be honest
I went in my bedroom and I wept I cried
hard
not just because my daughter said no to
me on our Valentine's Day but because I
know I've been a mess
and it spills onto people at work spills
on wife
[Music]
and now it's been one of my kids
I've been avoiding dealing with my own
crap for a long time and my daughter's
body called me out on it
it's my job to deal with my emotions not
hers
it's our jobs adults to be the adults
and to go seek out relationships and
support and help from other adults not
our kids
they got enough of their own crap to be
carrying to not carry us
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
thank you
all right as we wrap up today's show man
this is the uh
lyrical Masterpiece some people don't
understand that AC DC is actually a
group of poets
check out these incredible lyrics from
the classic Thunderstruck
Thunder
I was caught in the middle of a railroad
track fun now I looked around I knew
there was no turning back
my mind raced and I thought what could I
do
and I knew there was no help no help
from you
sound of the drums beating in my heart
the Thunder of guns tore me apart
you know what this means because I don't
there was Thunder and then he was on a
train track so now there's drums and
hearts and guns
I love y'all see you later
[Music]